so the Internet is pretty much hating on
Ben Affleck right now because of the
whole Batman thing I got to tell you
this is not the movie that he needs to
be out right now runner-runner stars
Justin Timberlake Ben Affleck Gemma
Arterton and Anthony Mackie this movies
basically about a guy Ben Affleck who
started his own website it was an online
gambling website it became very
successful Justin Timberlake then
Gamble's on this website and he believes
that he has been cheated and he can
prove it so he decides to go and find
Ben Affleck and say look I can prove
this with numbers you cheated me I can
send you to jail or you can give me a
job and when Ben Affleck gives him a job
in this company he doesn't turn out to
be everything he thinks it's going to be
even though there's a lot of dollar
signs attached to it this movie's
written by some pretty good writers who
know a lot about poker and gambling they
wrote movies like rounders and Ocean's
thirteen it's directed by the guy whose
last film was The Lincoln Lawyer which I
thought was really good
so it's really strange for me to say how
bland and mediocre this movie turned out
there really isn't anything behind this
movie that actually made me invested in
it in fact within minutes of driving
home from the theater I wasn't even
thinking about it anymore
I don't dislike Justin Timberlake at all
I think he's fine I just don't really
buy him that much in this movie as an
actor he kind of fits in the movie but
like II just I don't know if it's the
character or his dialogue I just didn't
really feel him as a character I mean he
was fine in the movie it just there
wasn't it really I just kept seeing
Justin Timberlake that's my best way to
describe it and I really do like Ben
Affleck and I am sort of on his team for
the whole Batman thing I think he'll do
a good job but in this movie it's not
that he's doing a bad job it's really
it's not that anyone in the film is
actually doing a bad performance or
being sucky as their character it's just
that they're so uninteresting characters
the script doesn't have anything behind
it that makes you care about these
people it's just all these little plot
points that happen and they create semi
interesting scenes but when you add them
up as a whole and watch them strung
together it doesn't create an even
remotely interesting movie I wouldn't
say that anyone in this film is bad I
wouldn't say that Wow Ben Affleck is so
bad in this movie this movie sucks cuz
it's Ben Affleck or this movie sucks cuz
Justin Timberlake it just feels like the
writers of the script were uninterested
in writing it so the movie itself gets
really boring and it's funny because I
read an interview with
two writers who were like yeah we
finally decided to make another gambling
poker movie like they said it as if they
were working you know what I mean like
we're gonna work on this script because
they would like us to think you could
tell they were just tired of writing
gambling movies I found myself semi
invested in some aspects of the story
but some of it gets so jumbled and
convoluted and really inconsistent like
it'll be a big chase scene where this
running around and of course the
director feels the need to shake the
camera because that's what all directors
do nowadays I don't know why he did a
good job with the Lincoln Lawyer here it
just kind of felt like he was not paying
attention and it'll be like a really
poignant scene between two characters
and then it'll be a gambling scene it
doesn't feel as if there's a natural
progression of emotion it just feels
like actors who are trying to do their
best to do well in the specific scene
that they are in at that moment but this
doesn't feel meshed like it's an entire
film it just feels like a very
uninteresting bland mediocre movie and
that's what runner-runner was to me I'm
gonna give Renner runner a c-minus I
think that it's just left so guys I
recently called in to the schmoes know
podcast and if you guys a note that is
it's my buddy's the schmoes who are also
on YouTube they do a podcast once a week
where they talked to various film stars
and people who are involved in the
entertainment field and they talk about
everything and it's really entertaining
I suggest you guys check it out I got a
chance to call in and talk a lot about
Breaking Bad and my thoughts on the
whole show I left a link for that in the
description below you can go and listen
to it or watch a video I hope you guys
do check that out and check out their
show in the future cuz it's pretty
entertaining guys thanks as always very
much for watching and of course if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes